hello everyone welcome to a very nice
game from round 9 of the 2019 u.s.
championship it's again between Ray
Robson and Hikaru Nakamura a Nakamura is
in the lead currently and well he does
have the black pieces so he's facing the
younger the lower rated opponent how
will he deal with this game and what
opening will he choose it's a very
interesting concept if you will but
before we get to that and it really is a
wonderful game I would just like to
invite everyone to check out the first
link in the description below it's a
trailer for the Gran catches classic
tournament created by the grantee chess
video team they've contacted me and they
said that if I will be covering any
games from the Greinke chess classic
that I'm more than welcome to use
they're both the video and well both
footage and photos from our from the
event so we can all enjoy some nice
photos of all the participants which i
think is always not the most important
part but are really important parts of
you not only see the board the moves but
you also get the the feel for the entire
event and well if you're new to the
chess world you'll also learn who is who
you know how the who drinks what during
a chess game and all the all the nice
ideas who dresses a how far a chess game
and and so on so I think it's very nice
for the of them to contact me and offer
me such such courtesies and I would I
would like to invite everyone to check
out the trailer they've created for for
the range just classic tournament it's
really nice really talk to your footage
of all the top players I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it do check it out like I
said first link in the description below
you will enjoy it
I enjoyed it myself several times in
fact and you know feel free to give it a
like a comment and and everything that
follows that being said I do hope you
enjoyed it and well if you have you are
an excellent watcher of trailers for
chess tournaments let's get back to the
game so ray Robson versus Hikaru
Nakamura 2019 US Championship Robson
opens with E for an OK Nakamura goes for
c5 sorry about that the Sicilian defense
is on the
we have Nitro 3 D 6 and D for just the
normal standard stuff you do when you
face the Sicilian defense night to have
sex by hikaru night the c3 and here's
the word becomes interesting and a
camera goes g6 and we entered the dragon
variation of the Sicilian now which is
something well not everyone there's the
play against well against the
Grandmaster when Grandmaster plays with
the white pieces as as the Bobby Fischer
often said it's it's too easy to play
this for white you will just play f3 g4
h4 h5 and crushed black well we'll see
what happens in this game Robson
continues with Bishop to e3 the standard
idea preparing Queen to d2 to challenge
blacks the dark square Bishop with
Bishop to g7 Nakamura fianchetto the
bishop prepares the castle and now we
have f3 preparing the Yugoslav attack we
have castles by Nakamura
Queen to d2 now this powerful Queen
Bishop barrier is ready to do the trade
off we have nice to see 6 and now Bishop
to c4
we have Bishop to d7 queenside castle by
white and now rook to b8 preparing to
push on the Queen side we have Bishop to
b3 not allowing b5 to come with an
attack on the bishop and not nice day 5
with ideas of trading of the night for
this very strong light square bishop we
have bunch of to h6 and here nakamura
immediately threads of the dark square
bishop in some lines you will want to
wait until white captures on g7 but here
if you play a slow move then white will
definitely start pushing with h4 and if
b5 and then just captures captures and
well h5 is coming you are already
threatening to exchange and infiltrate
with the Queen
so here Nakamura immediately trades it
off Bishop captures we have Queen
captures on h6 and now b5 starting an
expansion of his own on the Queen side
Knight to d5 with Knight capture son b3
first getting rid of it with Czech
Knight captures and now II five now
after the Knights are traded off which
they are we have captures with Czech
nakamura recaptures also the Queen now
guards the d6 pawn and here there this
has all been played before I mean
the dragon has been played for for many
years and there are a lot of games in
the database there is one game in the
database where look to d3 was played
would ideas of f4 and ringing this
recover to h3 so a nice rook lift but in
this game Robson goes for h4 immediately
wants to push and bust open the kingside
and it's only as of this move from move
17 that we have now a completely new
game that's okay Nakamura goes rook to
b6 I'll bring in further defense to them
that a d6 pawn also this rook can now
enter the game and perhaps a doubling of
rooks on the C file may occur
we have h5 white starts well trying to
bust open the Kings side using this pawn
that is often called a ram in in chess
well as use it to bust open the door to
the king's castle and now Queen to e7
the best defense now when pawn captures
Nakamura recaptures with the f1 and now
the Queen guards the h7 point so here
it's not really clear how will white
increase the pressure here if you try
something like roof to h4 bring the
other rock over to h1 yes you can triple
on the edge file but just rook f7 keeps
everything in check unless you find a
way to bring the knight into the game
you're not not gonna have a successful
attack here and Nakamura is definitely
ready with to push his own points on the
Queen side
so here Robson goes back we have Queen
t3 preventing the pushing of the pawn
because the Queen now eyes the rook on
the b6 square
so first Bishop to e6 by black we have
rook H to f1 now preparing f4 and now
comes Luke the c6 now Nakamura shifts
the attention of the rooks towards the C
file where the King is situated we have
f4 by white and now comes Queen to c7
with threats of rook captures on c2 we
have looked to d2 by white defending the
the C do pawn and now comes a five now
Nakamura finally is ready to push
King to be one getting the King away
from the C file but also making room for
the night on c1 with a four by black
knight to see one now and now B for
preparing ideas like B 3 or a 3
depending on how white proceeds and now
comes rugged D 2 F 2 which is well it's
a
interesting idea but this rook is pretty
much stuck guarding the c2 pond so it's
not all that clear what good it will do
and on the F file but okay I'm Nakamura
captures we have each actress on f4 rook
captures on f4 and now not immediately
of course you cannot capture due to real
characters on f8 first Nakamura goes
rock the sea it triples on the C file
and now it's not all that clear how you
will defend the c2 pawn if you try
something like Knight e - with ideas of
after rook captures you go Knight d4 and
well you hope to pick up the bishop not
really gonna work because Bishop to c4
just switches the attention towards the
rook and now after Knight captures you
will capture with the bishop and white
will not be able to recapture if you
recapture you get captures here after
King a1 black is very close to a to a
winning position but - you know in in in
hands of Nakamura surely it would be
most likely a winning game so I have to
rip the c8 Robson tried rook to f6 he
says okay you can take my seat upon I'm
gonna grab your Bishop and Nakamura
decides okay you can have my Bishop he
plays rook captures on c2 so a piece
sacrifice but you know it will bring a
lot of activity towards the black we
have rook captures only six white
accepts the piece sacrifice and now
nakamura goes for Queen to c4 just
attacking both of the rooks and
repositioning the Queen so the Queen
will now be closer to the white king we
have look e to f6 now both rooks now
guard each other but now comes a three
and it's already a very dangerous
position nakamura is down a piece but if
you just play let's say slow move Queen
h6 it's not a slow move but already are
threatening the rook to f8 which will
follow with checkmate black can black
can win this game because black has a
nice force checkmate but you know it's a
nice complicated position feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
winning idea which of course did not
happen in the game I'll give you a
couple of seconds to decide whether we
want to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent winner of positions
that have not occurred in the game
and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show look capture Sun B -
that's the idea
and after King to a one now you cannot
capture here and deliver checkmate
because notice that the Queen and rook
guard the night and c1 so you cannot
sacrifice the Queen for checkmate but
what you can do is sacrifice the rook
rugby one check this is the move you had
to find force the King to go here and
now is just Quincey to check King moves
and Queen to be to checkmate so a very
poisonous position after this a3 idea by
Nakamura so Rob's and decides to capture
it we have pawn captures and Nakamura
recaptures now the B file also opens up
for black to use in his attack and Queen
captures on a3 by Robson so what do you
play here it's a very interesting
position so I will ask you to pause the
video again and try to find how to
continue the attack for black here as
this position did happen in the game
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
winner of positions that have indeed
occurred in the game and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show not
rook to b8 check if you deliver this
check then the knight can simply cover
up what Knight to b3 and it's not not
all that clear how white will white will
how black will continue here the move
you had to find was rook captures on c1
with check this is what Nakamura played
we have rook captures on c1 with an
attack on the Queen and now comes Queen
captures on e4 with check and now pink
the b2 now you might think okay but
working to b2 y la Queen e5 check to
pick up the rook the problem is if you
go quick a king to a-1 then you get 25
check queen of course will block and now
rook captures on c1 will be checkmate
because the Queen cannot capture the
queen is now pinned so that's why Robson
goes for King 2b - and now we have 25
check rug blocks and now first before
recapturing rook to b8 check by Nakamura
King c2 and only now Queen captures on
f6 so now after everything is said and
done you can see that Nakamura even
though he started this whole venture
with a piece sacrifice he ended up being
up upon so not definitely not bad and
the whites King is well blacks King
isn't all that safe either but White's
king is well
very very loose nice okay look we have
three by Robson with Queen Taddy for now
just an Isis centralizing move we have
looked back to be three offering a trade
of rooks and now first Queen to e4 check
with King to c1 and now Queen e1 check
not Queen to Yvonne Chaka Queen to e1
check as a lot of you do say that in the
comments Kings the c2 now Queen e2 check
King to b1 and of course Queen d1 check
and now white will have to trade if you
go King b2 then rook c8 and you're
getting check mated very quickly so here
Robson had to trade we have Queen to c1
but now first you will grab yet another
pawn rook captures on b3 with check pawn
captures Queen captures now of course
you cannot trade Queens because you are
down in in a King and pawn and game
being down two points will be completely
winning for black so here King day one
was played Queen a4 check just a few
checks to get where were black wants to
go King b5 check King gay one and now
Queen c5 offers a trade of Queens white
of course declines we have Queen to d2
and now h5 King back to be one with King
to g7 Queen to be to check we have Queen
to e5 blocking again white has no option
of of trading Queen's Queen b7 check we
are Kings to h6
and now King to c1 we have d5 now
Nakamura starts pushing his passed pawn
king to d1 and now Queen to b4 with
Queen to be - now comes King to g5 Queen
to d2 check and now kink the g4 and
after Queen to h6 here Nakamura just
played g5 and it was in his position
animal 55 that rail Robson resigned to
the game why did he resign there are no
more any any tricky moves you can't
really even hope for anything here you
are done two pawns and well even one
point in a queen and pawn endgame is
almost always winning for the other side
that has the extra pawn but which two
points it's it's never even a question
although I don't know if if the roles
were reversed I'm sure Nakamura would
continue this game and hope for a
blunder or some sort of a super sneaky
tricky I don't know chess study position
that
I entered the books someday how about
and not Rob's and Robson decided that
it's me besides the point
and he just resigned here which was a
very important victory for Hikaru
Nakamura as it was with the black pieces
and it's a very brave of him to choose
the dragon Sicilian which basically just
invites white attack - attack - attack
which Robson did Nakamura repel the
attacks successfully and then he started
this counter-attack which was well in
this game decisive but definitely a
brave decision to go for the dragon
pretty much everyone won their games I
think only only Sheung drew to his game
a true his gaming in round 9 so it was a
really decisive round Quran also won a
very nice game using the dodge defense
so that was also a very nice game but
yeah and Nakamura and Lanier Dominguez
Paras are in the lead now after nine
rounds not Khurana follows with six
points Nakamura and Dominguez are with
six and a half and the rest the follow
and today we have we have the clash of
leaders Nakamura will face Dominguez and
we will see who will take take the lead
here either
one of them will win and then remain the
sole leader or they might draw and then
Khurana might get a chance to overtake
the lead we'll see how it goes
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it once again do check out the
trailer for the grand caches classic
it's really just wonderful it will be
again the first thing you will see in
the description below do check it out
I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it I would
like to thank Andrew driver
Alex Robinson Joseph D Robert berry
McMurray doc and Anton Kukushkin for a
contribution to my channel thank you
what I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon I almost likely with some of
the games from the US Championship at
European Championship finished and then
before some key or grand K we are
definite to continue in the Capablanca
saga see where it takes us thank you all
and I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your Saturday